Joe Biden steps all over himself on
national television
Pete Budaj edge and Bernie Sanders
unveiled their foreign policy radicalism
and Democrats moved to call Republicans
Bluff on transparency i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today and Express VPN calm / button ok
we have a ton to get to today we're
gonna begin with Joe Biden so the polls
show that Joe Biden continues to
maintain this national lead he is still
considered the Democratic frontrunner
even though the betting markets have
Elizabeth Warren above Joe Biden at this
point but every time Joe Biden is on TV
raises question literally every time it
raises questions from the left about why
exactly this guy is the front-runner so
over the weekend Joe Biden was on 60
minutes and he was trying to explain why
it is that barack obama has not endorsed
him yet if you're such a great candidate
why is it that you were the VP and then
there was the president that you served
under and he looks like he refuses to
endorse you I mean he and thus he
endorsed Justin Trudeau up in Canada
like that guy but he didn't endorse you
so why so Joe Biden has to come up with
some sort of credible excuse and instead
he comes with a very non credible excuse
here is Joe Biden saying no no you know
I'm I'm just like I'm like the the son
of a famous guy I want to do it all on
my own on my own just like every son of
every famous person should just like huh
Hunter yet no here was Joe Biden trying
to explain why Barack Obama has not yet
intervened in the 2020 election to back
him some of us why hasn't President
Obama endorsed you you guys served
together for eight years because I have
to earn I want to earn this on my own
did he offer to endorse you no we didn't
even get there I asked him not to he
said okay I think it's better I think he
thinks it's better for me I have no
doubt when I'm the nominee he'll be out
the campaign trail for me yeah and when
you're the nominee but that's not the
question
of course you would be he was on the
campaign trail for Hillary Clinton last
time you could nominate you could
nominate Cory Booker and he'd be out on
the trail but you could nominate a Seth
Bullock
well there's any sense boy what's the
name of the guy but governor Bullock it
not set buh except folks the guy from -
from from from Deadwood Bullock the the
governor of Montana you can nominate
that guy and Obama would be out on the
trail for him but the fact is that Joe
Biden is making excuses here and it's
pretty obvious he's making excuses here
because he's running a very weak race
and a lot of that weakness is again
based on his own vulnerabilities here's
the thing about running against Donald
Trump every time you attack Trump
better be clean on the score upon which
you are attacking Trump because if
you're not it is going to come back and
it's going to bite you directly in the
ass President Trump has no problem
whatsoever with turnabout s fair play
and the problem for Joe Biden is that
half the stuff that he says can easily
be turned on him so let me give you an
example Joe Biden was in the sixty
minutes interview and he also said that
Donald Trump's children should not be
working in the White House that it's a
full-on disaster that Donald Trump's
kids in Vanka and her husband Jared are
working in the White House obviously
that is quite terrible stuff you
wouldn't want this kind of nepotism
working in the White House I mean it
would be terrible if somebody had like a
child would say a son who is absolutely
profiting off his father's name like
hunt like like hunter here is Joe Biden
going after Trump's children if I'm
president get elected president my
children are not gonna have offices in
the White House my children are not
going to sit in on cabinet meetings
what's improper about that that's just
simply improper because you should make
it clear to the American public that
everything you're doing is for them for
them and the idea that you're gonna have
these children as son-in-law etc engaged
in the day-to-day operation of things
they know nothing about just so you
don't think Jared Kushner should be
negotiating a Middle East peace solution
no I don't don't what what credential
does he bring to that I mean what
credentials does Jared Kushner
bring to the business of Middle East
peace I mean like it would be terrible
if he had a son who was going around you
know with no credentials just getting
involved in in foreign places around the
world and using your name as credibility
in order to get things done for himself
right self-dealing that'd be just awful
you know just like hunter Biden so
there's the story from NBC News
yesterday quote hunter Biden's legal
work in Romania raises new questions
about his overseas dealings question did
hundred Biden not take money in any
country the this guy's doing where in
the world is Carmen Sandiego at this
point where in the world is Carmen's at
waist hunter Biden I mean it just like
Ukraine China Romania it really is I
used to I used to play that that Carmen
Sandiego computer game as a kid just
like everybody from my era did and it
just it's hunter Biden he's wearing like
the the fedora and he's wearing the high
collared trenchcoat he's going around
picking up money in various countries is
there anywhere hunter Biden wasn't using
his father's name this according to NBC
News again this is bad according to
Daily wire or Daily Caller or Breitbart
this is according to NBC News in the
final year of the Obama administration
an American Lawyer traveled to Romania
to meet with a businessman accused of
orchestrating a corrupt land deal the
businessman was Gabriel Pugh E Hui
Popovich U and spelled PU iu that's why
you have I'm having some trouble reading
it we hope of it you a wealthy Romanian
real estate tycoon the lawyer brought in
to advise him was hunter Biden the son
of then Vice President Joe Biden
according to two people familiar with
the matter because when you are having a
trouble with Romanian real estate deal
you're like I want the best you know I'm
a wealthy real estate tycoon I need the
best lawyer I need the Perry Mason of
this thing we need the best lawyer
somebody get me hunter Biden you know
the guy who was just kicked out of the
Navy for alleged drug use that guy right
like that look that's who I need hunter
Biden's work for Popovich you in 2016
when unreported at the time weird
because everything that Ivanka Trump
interned cushion has ever done has been
reported just gonna point that out but
Joe Biden's involvement in Romania was
very much public the VP was among the
leading voices pushing the government to
crack down on corruption there's no
evidence that hunter or his father acted
improperly or violated any laws but the
arrangement government ethics experts
say raises concern that hunter Biden was
used as a prop in Popovich's efforts to
dodge criminal prosecution Kathleen
Clark Washington University law
professor says we don't know what hunter
Biden was paid or what he was paid for
but it does raise questions of whether
this Romanian individual facing criminal
charges was actually paying for a
connection to the American
vice-president hunter Biden's work
overseas primarily in Ukraine and China
has become a subject of the presidential
campaign through the efforts of Trump
and his personal where Rudy Giuliani to
portray the international dealings as
corrupt and does it look kind of corrupt
at Hunter Biden again was acting as sort
of random bagman legal bagman for
everybody on earth
you hear me popping up in a Hungary soon
we're gonna find out that he was in
Chile for some odd reason he's just
lawyering up some cattle deal in Chile
or something based on his vast knowledge
of Agriculture at some point you would
have figured that Joe Biden read captain
anti-corruption will just
kept in with hunter and said listen
we're gonna have plenty of money I'm the
vice president to the United States
we're not gonna be short on cash or
hunter just hold up
just slow your roll for five seconds
here until I'm no longer vice president
of the United States and then you can go
make whatever speeches you want but he
never apparently said this to Hunter
apparently he was just like you know
what go ahead and do anyone now it's
funny cuz the media keep going there's
no evidence that there's any corruption
here okay show me the evidence that
Jared Kushner has profited wildly from
being stuck in the office next to his
father-in-law listening to his
father-in-law's tirades about the Middle
East like show me how Jared Kushner is
just raking in the dough that way as
opposed to when he was doing you know
hundred million dollar real estate deals
in New York City and not having to deal
with all of this last week hunter Biden
announced he would step down from the
board of the Chinese investment company
he joined in October 2017 it's very
weird also the timing of 100 Biden is
stepping down from the stuff and he
stepped down from burries MA
like right after Joe announced and now
he's stepping down from that Chinese
Board like now when all the focus is on
him are we wrong to be suspicious about
all this is why Biden and his candidacy
are extremely extremely weak we didn't
get into more of that in just one second
first gotta tell you I am deeply
concerned about safety I mean we spend
lots and lots of money at this company
on my personal safety unfortunately
because there's just a lot of threats
against me what that means is that I
really want to know who's at my front
door at all times if somebody brings
that door about I want to know who it is
before I go out to the gate and pick up
that FedEx package safety is really
important to me that is why I use ring
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you'll get an alert and you'll be able
to see hear and speak to them all from
your phone this makes me feel safer I
mean right now we are 8,000 miles away
from home and I still know who's at my
front door I mean like my wife's phone
jangles every time there is somebody at
the front door which is great we want to
know who exactly is around our property
as a subscriber you have a special offer
on a ring welcome kit available right
now at ring.com slash been the kit
includes that ring video doorbell - and
a chime Pro which is just what you need
to start building a ring of security
around your home today so go to ring.com
slash band that is ring.com
slash been additional terms may apply I
love ring and you will too okay so as I
say Joe Biden's candidacy is weak
because every area of attack is an area
in which he is fully capable of being
attacked it's the same thing
happened with Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton thought I'm going to attack
Donald Trump on his rampant vicious
brutal sexism I'm gonna go after him on
E
I'm gonna grab people that she was gonna
go after there's only one problem
you are married to Bill Clinton and
according to some of Bill Clinton's
victims you were threatening them right
so if you are going to attack somebody
you at least have to be somewhat clean
on the score upon which you are
attacking people right and that is not
the case with Joe Biden another example
so Joe Biden is on TV calling Trump an
idiot for calling the Russia
investigation a hoax well Joe Biden last
I checked has been on TV suggesting that
any implication of any corruption with
regard to hunter Biden is a hoax uh neva
densed and nonsense so which is it do
you get to call investigations targeting
your hoax or not like what what exactly
it how is this going I'm just confused
what is the standard for when you are
allowed to say that an investigation
targeting you in which you know yourself
to be innocent is a hoax
here is Joe Biden saying the Trump is an
idiot for using that sort of verbiage
I mean how concerned are you about
foreign interference in this election
I'm very concerned about foreign
interference beyond me everybody knows
what's going on
Trump not only doesn't want to do
anything about it he's going out and
asking for help come help me come help
me defeat keep fighting from being the
nominee I mean how is he perpetuating it
well by encouraging them to you know to
get involved in our elections but
President Trump says Russian
interference is a hoax
he's an idiot on terms of saying that
everybody knows this everybody knows it
nobody doubts it okay so again Joe Biden
is not the best messenger for the
Democratic Party the problem is they
don't have a good messenger so it's
funny you watch Democrats these days and
they keep appealing to Republicans they
keep repealing to people who who didn't
vote to for Trump in 2016 but are more
likely to vote for him in 2020 and like
well look at all the stuff that Trump's
doing and I'll admit a lot of stuff that
Trump says I cringe right there's a lot
of stuff that Trump does that I cringe
and then I look at you guys and I'm like
if you think I am voting for you you are
out of your mind you're out of your mind
I mean first of all Joe Biden is an
incredibly weak candidate who is
susceptible on a lot of these scores
second of all Elizabeth Warren
is a radical and a damned liar okay
there's an article in The New York Times
today talking about Elizabeth wardens
random sudden shift against big
corporations right now she spends her
days ripping on big corporations they're
so evil they hate American citizens they
don't care about you she was happy to
take their money she was really happy to
take their money according to the New
York Times Elizabeth Warren had never
taken on the federal government before
but in 1995 she found herself up against
the Clinton administration representing
the Cleveland based conglomerate LTV
steel even though LTV had sold off its
coal mines during the 1980s a new law
required it to contribute to a health
fund for retired miners LTV believed it
should not have to pay those claims the
company said should have been handled as
part of its bankruptcy reorganization
Warren's job was to convince the Supreme
Court to hear LTVs case the court
declined but from its war in the issue
in fester over a decade later when she
ran for Senate from Massachusetts in
2012 the Republican incumbent Senator
Scott Brown in Massachusetts tried to
use her work for LTV against her
unleashing an ad calling her a hired gun
who sided against working people the LTV
case was part of a considerable body of
legal work that Miss Warren one of the
nation's leading bankruptcy experts took
on while working as a law professor
moonlighting that earned her hundreds of
thousands of dollars over roughly two
decades beginning in the late 1980s
mostly while she was on the faculty at
Harvard much of it involves representing
big corporate clients because elizabeth
warren is a deeply unprincipled human
being elizabeth warren is happy to take
the check when it benefits her but then
she's going to turn into bernie sanders
on steroids as soon as it benefits her
to do that according to the New York
Times The New York Times going after
more now Miss Warren has ascended toward
the head of the Democratic presidential
PAC on the strength of her populist
appeal and progressive plans which
include breaking up big tech companies
free public college and a wealth tax on
the richest Americans her political
opponents in turn have sought to find a
soft spot on issues of authenticity
chiefly miss Warren's handling of her
claim to Native American ancestry upon
the against that backdrop some of Miss
morons critics have seized upon her
bankruptcy work for LTV and other big
corporations to question the depth of
her progressive at bona fide ease how
they wonder could someone whose
reputation is built on consumer advocacy
have represented a company seeking to
avoid paying for retired minors health
care miss Warren's campaign did not make
her available to discuss her outside
legal work she's good with the selfies
she's not good with answering questions
as we know and she likes to talk about
oh these thousands of selfies first of
all
it's not a selfie when it's just a photo
line yeah I do lots and photo lines
those are not all selfies but put aside
the the silliness of the selfies she
doesn't want to talk about what her
health care plan is going to cost her
how she's going to pay for it how she's
gonna pay for by latest estimates 42
trillion dollars in spending over the
next 10 years and she doesn't explain
how exactly that that's gonna be paid
for by a 2% wealth tax the answer is
it's not she doesn't want to answer
questions about her history she doesn't
want to explain why she shifted on
school vouchers from very much pro in
2003-2004 to extraordinarily against in
2019 just when she needs the support of
the American Federation of Teachers
weird isn't it she's deeply inauthentic
hey even the New York Times is pointing
it out over the years Warren has twice
released accounts of her practice a
partial list of cases in 2012 and a
fuller list of more than 50 cases posted
to her presidential campaign in May
among her corporate clients or
traveler's insurance the aircraft maker
Fairchild as well as one of America's
wealthiest families the hunts of Texas
she advocated for a railroad company
that wanted to avoid paying for a
Superfund cleanup and advised alchemical
as its subsidiary Dell Corning dealt
with thousands of complaints from women
who said they'd been harmed by its
silicone breast implants but she also
worked on a number of cases involving
consumer bankruptcy and victims rights
and asbestos litigation in very brief
and simplified summaries the list cast
much of her work even for corporate
clients in terms that align with her pro
consumer narrative those descriptions
have themselves become a focus of some
contention a review by the New York
Times reveals a complex picture in which
many cases defy simple black or white
categorization it offers a look at a
relatively unexamined aspect of her
thinking when they say it defies simple
black or white categorization that is to
say no she was not a thoroughgoing
progressive when she was willing to take
the cash okay that's the that's the
reality of Elizabeth Warren and get some
more of that her inauthenticity in just
one second first let's talk about
something really important that is
preserving your memories so right now
for example I am on this trip to Israel
we've taken tons and tons of pictures
now we have those pictures digitally
available but if I had taken this trip
even 15 years ago I wouldn't have that
ability if I'd taken this trip 15 years
ago I'd probably have to go print out
the film and then all of that stuff
would be moldering in a garage somewhere
instead of being available to meet with
one click of button
and if it were my parents my parents had
taken this trip then it would be on old
film reels probably well if you got any
of those old film reels heading those
old photos that are stuck in your garage
and they're just falling apart rotting
away getting mildewed or if you're
afraid that you're gonna have to move
and negative Shep these boxes of stuff
well I have a really great solution it's
called legacy box you can save your
family films and photos from degrading
or being lost forever
you might have those old VHS tapes but
you don't have a VCR anymore so what
good do those do you you can get all of
those transferred to a digital format
you can experience the joy and nostalgia
of looking back at all of the good times
send your legacy box filled with old
home movies and pictures and then legacy
box does the rest they professionally
digitize your moments onto a thumb drive
digital download or DVD they've got
easy-to-follow instructions safety bar
codes included for every item it's the
world's largest most trusted digitizer
of home movies and photos go check them
out right now there's never been a
better time to digitally preserve your
memories visit legacy box comm today to
get started plus for a limited time
they're offering my listeners an
exclusive discount go to legacy box comm
slash Shapiro's to get 40% off your
first order again go to legacy box calm
slash up hero save 40% today get started
preserving your past legacy box comm
slash up hero save 40% today okay so the
New York Times going after Elizabeth
Warren her work the scholars say should
be understood primarily as an effort to
preserve the rights and file for
bankruptcy and the integrity of the
bankruptcy system oh it's just that she
was being happy to be paid by by giant
corporations to take care of all of that
according to this law professor Douglas
Baird at University of Chicago he says
he's not her political supporter he says
Warren was simply advocating for clients
not necessarily with an eye toward the
future popularity of her positions
lawyers he said are to some extent
plumbers or mechanics trying to be
zealous advocates for their clients oh
isn't that Oh or or maybe just wanted
the money
in 1998 the Harvard Crimson reported
Warren was paid 192 thousand dollars in
salary plus one hundred and thirty four
thousand dollars another compensation
which is a pretty sweet gig probably she
made more than half a million dollars
from her legal consultancy according to
the New York Times
most of the work fell outside the period
when she was required to submit
financial disclosure reports travelers
paid her more than two hundred thousand
dollars over several years for advice on
dealing with asbestos claims against
it's insured John Banville for example
so this is definitely it's definitely
questionable when it comes to when it
comes to Elizabeth Warren for sure and
there gonna be a lot of attack ads on
Elizabeth Lawrence it's an
extraordinarily weak feel but then he
gets the actual radicalism of the field
so yesterday a bunch of Democratic
candidates appeared at a group called J
Street J Street is an radical
anti-israel group that purports to be a
Jewish group most of the people who or
at least a lot of the people who are in
the leading positions at J Street have
no actual relationship with Judaism or
Israel they're just anti-israel people
who happen to have a Jewish last name
are ethnically Jewish they don't care
about Israel they hate Israel they've
supported boycotts invest in sanctions
in the past at least many of their chief
people have they are routinely routinely
take positions that are antithetical to
the safety and security of the State of
Israel they're awful for the State of
Israel and so naturally Democrats trot
them out as pretend israel supporters
because the fact is that most people who
actually support israel in the united
states recognize the democratic party
has moved away from a correct position
on this issue a morally justifiable
position on this issue and instead
they've moved into the realm of
supporting Israel's opponents namely
Hamas Hezbollah Islamic Jihad and the
Palestinian Authority and because that's
the choice over here okay the choice is
not between Israel and some nice happy
Dappy do government's on the other side
the Palestinian Authority is a terror
group that names streets after
terrorists and pays families of
terrorists after the terrorists go and
commit suicide bombings or killings the
Palestinian Authority is currently in a
joint government with Hamas which is an
overt terrorist group which has been
firing rockets into Israel fairly
routinely firing incendiary kites and
balloons into Israel fairly routinely
building terror tunnels to try and
kidnap Israeli citizens spending
millions and millions of dollars in
order to do all of this stuff okay that
they're in a joint government with the
Palestinian Authority Islamic Jihad is a
terrorist group these are all terrorist
groups and when people call on Israel to
negotiate with these terror groups the
question is why why would Israel ever do
that well the Democrats have been
calling on Israel to do all of that
because the Democrats have a view of
foreign policy in which Israel is rich
and big and bad because it is rich and
therefore the people that Israel is
facing down can't be terrorists there
are just sort of unsung multicultural
heroes there people who have been put
upon
by the by the West there people have
been put upon by Israel the poverty of
Palestinians is not due to the Arab
world's refusal to take them in over the
last 70 years or provide them any sort
of funding over the last 70 years it is
not due to the Palestinian leadership
inability to come to any sort of deal a
deal offered by Yitzhak Rabin or a deal
offered by Benjamin Netanyahu and why
River or a deal offered by a hood Barak
or a deal offered by oh hold on there it
doesn't matter right none of those
matter the only thing the matter is that
Israel is big and bad in military
militarily powerful and the Palestinians
are poor little victims no there's only
a couple of groups in the United States
that purport to have any relationship
with Jews that take this position one is
J Street which again is an awful
terrible organization filled with damned
liars and so this is where the Democrats
go they stop by J Street to pretend the
J Street is natural legitimate
organization a glue tournament
pro-israel organization or an Israel
advocacy organization when it is not it
is a front group for people who despise
the State of Israel so Democrats show up
to talk to J Street right they wouldn't
show up to AIPAC right now one of these
people showed up to AIPAC now I am NOT a
big believer in APAC right APEC is the
American Israel Public Affairs Committee
I have never been a huge advocate of
AIPAC because I think that AIPAC lends
credence to people who are overtly
anti-israel AIPAC will invite nearly
anybody to speak to AIPAC they will fly
people to Israel who take terribly
anti-israel positions pro-iranian
positions they'll provide cover for
those people but at least AIPAC is
actually a pro-israel organization
overall right at least the AIPAC takes
the position that Israel is a morally
justified state that should exist Jai
Sri doesn't really believe it rude in
the existence of the State of Israel if
they could go back 70 out 71 years and
just erase its existence they absolutely
would they say if they're not saying so
overtly they are certainly saying so
behind closed doors they despise the
State of Israel
okay so Democrats have gone there to
make overtures to J Street and they're
taking extraordinarily radical positions
right there so-called moderates are
taking extraordinary radical positions
so people D judge who's the newfound
moderate right he's the voice of
moderation in the Democratic Party he
didn't just go there and push the Iran
deal which would you would expect that
from every Democrat at this point
they'll push this garbage or anzio that
allowed Iran to develop long-range
ballistic missiles and fun terror all
over the Middle East with Americans
allowing dollars to flow in
to Iran and all they had to do was
basically pledged that for 10 years they
wouldn't develop nuclear weapons making
sure that in a heartbeat they could turn
those machines right back on as soon as
the 10-year period is over and they
could have the money and they could have
the terrorists support and they could
have the ballistic missiles it's a
terrible terrible horrible deal the Iran
deal but Obama cut it so obviously
Democrats are gonna say that it's good
but it's not even that that I'm talking
about here when I talk about Democratic
foreign policy radicalism I'm talking
about the Democrats now making overt
that they wish to cut all military aid
to Israel on the grounds that Israel
won't make deals with terrorists okay
there you might call it a quid pro quo
they're actually saying out loud that
they would cut military aid to Israel
over Israel not cutting a deal with
terrorists now if you want to say that
you want to cut military aid across the
board I'm kind of in favor
rayul is a strong country Israel has
been able historically to take care of
itself ever since 1973 okay the fact is
that Israel can buy weapons from the
United States without having to take
military loans if you want to say that
all of that I hear it I hear it I mean
listen it's still vital because Israel's
economy while strong is not enormous but
if you want to make that argument I kind
of hear that argument if you're making
the argument however that Israel should
be singled out for removal of military
aid when it is facing down terror groups
on literally every single one of its
borders you're out of your mind but
that's exactly what Democrats are doing
so when people say why won't you support
Democrats went on Olymp does X Y or Z
all I have to do is point all I have to
do this point because this is what the
Democrats stand for we're gonna get to
the Democrats radicalism in just one
second first let's talk about credit
card debt it is extremely easy to get
into credit card debt unfortunately I
know people who have gotten into tens of
thousands of dollars in credit card debt
and the next thing they know they're
looking around and those interest
charges are racking up at extraordinary
rates because very often they'll say oh
well you know you got this well you got
this deal to get into a credit card low
interest rates and then you miss your
payment by a month or two and suddenly
you're paying like twenty percent
interest rates it's very easy to get
stuck in this sort of cycle well you
should get out of it if you're a
responsible person what's the best way
to do that well you consolidate your
debt and you pay off your credit cards
with one fixed monthly payment this is
where Lending Club becomes in Lending
Club has helped millions of people
regain control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards just go to Lending Club calm
tell them about yourself and how much
you want to borrow and pick the
that are right for you if you're
approved your loan is automatically
deposited into your bank account in as
little as a few days Lending Club is
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
with over 35 billion dollars in loans
issued it is easy to get into debt
there's no reason to stay in debt go to
Lending Club comm slash Bend check your
rate in minutes borrow up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club comm / Ben Lending
Club comm / Ben all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender go
check them out right now ok so as I say
radicals on the Democratic side some
people to judge the supposed moderate
here's what he had to say about
threatening foreign aid to Israel and
folks are saying I'll see the deals no
good because they're doing all this well
of course that's not what the deal was
for the deal was to restrict nuclear
activity and it worked it worked
I believe the Obama administration got
this right that the one thing to
prioritize is to make sure they're not
nuclear would you also can consider
conditioning US aid to Israel as
leverage to stop or slow future
settlement construction if we continue
to see steps that are potentially
destructive I think it is a reminder
that we need to have the visibility to
know whether US funds are being used in
a way that's actually not compatible
with the US policy and US policy should
not be promoting this kind of settlement
construction okay now let me just be
clear about a couple of things in this
clip Peabody Judge is defending the Iran
deal in which the United States allows
dollars to flow to the Iranians for
terror use right for them to build
rockets and send them to Hezbollah like
Israel's greatest threat right now is
not from the Palestinians it's not
directly from Iran it's through
Hezbollah and its northern border within
three years Israel will likely be at war
in Lebanon because the prezbo la entity
in Lebanon which is in Iranian front
group is going to be firing rockets into
northern and central Israel in very
short order Israel have to go to
full-scale war there because that's a
terror group on their northern border
funded by Iran so people who do judge is
saying Iran feels good because we only
focused on nuclear so if they take all
that money and they spend it on
terrorism that's totally cool that's so
and that's why we should have signed on
to the deal right and then he's like
what but you know what we really should
do we should think about cutting off
money to Israel not to Iran to Israel we
should think about cutting off money if
they build extra bathrooms in East
Jerusalem that's the big problem is
people building apartment buildings in
in Efrat that's that's it's such a
problem people Jews living in areas
Wow really bad we can't have Jews living
in any of those areas why well because
how are you gonna make a peace deal if
you've got all of these areas where Jews
are living and the answer is the Jews
will live in Israel and then the
Palestinians will live in a state of
Palestine when they actually create a
government that is worthy of the name
that israel has offered to demolish
settlements before Israel has offered to
withdraw from certain areas Israel has
withdrawn and moved 6,000 people from
the Gaza Strip that was in 2005 you know
that resulted in the election of Hamas
and the firing of rockets into Israel on
a regular basis from Hamas sustained in
the Gaza Strip first of all the United
States coming from the position anybody
coming from the decision position
frankly that Judea and Samaria our
sovereign Palestinian territory knows
nothing about history knows nothing
about international law and the fact is
whose territory whose what entity what
entity owns that territory that was
Jordanian territory until 1967 at which
point they lost a war Israel has offered
that territory back to Jordan you know
what I'm on it the Jordanians because it
comes along with this entire Palestinian
population which unfortunately is by
poll numbers and by electioneering data
extraordinarily radicalized okay so
under international law this is a
disputed territory right even the the
famous UN resolution talking about
occupied territories it doesn't talk
about the occupied territories meaning
all of it it says some of these
territories are occupied and that is a
status for final negotiation but if
you're Israel why would you say to Jews
you're not allowed to settle anywhere in
this area you know we're gonna hold this
in abeyance for this terror group or
alternatively maybe the settlements are
actually a good pressure tactic to bring
somebody to the table because it's like
listen you want to make a deal and you
want to secure this particular portion
of land you know what you could do you
could make peace and stop trying to
murder people that'd be pretty good it
turns out by the way then when none of
this territory was in Israeli hands the
the Arab nations surrounding Israel
launched let's see the 56 war and the 67
war and then when it was in Israeli
hands they launched the 1973 war the Yom
Kippur War so ownership of the territory
does not have anything to do with the
effort to destroy Israel wholesale like
if you think the Palestinian how many
times must Israel offer to make a deal
including the land swaps right this is
what they talked about they talked about
okay so Israel will will take these
settlement areas and they will in court
into Israel proper and then they will
give them land swaps equivalent to that
amount of land nobody is talking about
dismantling any of the Palestinian areas
by the way that are in the so-called
West Bank and Chu dance merit but
there's people who to judge basically
saying let the money flow to Iran even
if they use it for terror but we got to
cut off this foreign military aid so
long as Jews keep building extra extra
bedrooms in in one of these so-called
settlements okay if by settlement they
mean a city that is in a disputed area
that's what a settlement is a settlement
is not people going into the middle of
Nablus and then declaring that Nablus is
sovereign Israeli territory forever and
we're just going to stay here forever
nobody wants knob loose okay let's beef
let's be frank about this nobody wants
Janeane nobody is interested in tool
karma like that is it's just its
absurdity but it wasn't just people who
judge making this case of course it's
Bernie Sanders who I do love when people
do this the media or like he'd be the
first Jewish president yes we'd be the
first ethnically Jewish president which
has as much to do with Judaism and being
Jewish like in terms of practice or
philosophy or Israel as as being frankly
being born Polish like it has nothing to
do with anything
hey Bernie Sanders despises the State of
Israel which is why he has been endorsed
by rashida to leave in Ojai Nomar and he
made that clear right he Bernie goes
even further right boo de jedge takes
the Obama position the Obama position as
Israel should stop with all of the
settlements activity who is very fraught
we can't have people building in in in
Kiryat Shmona we can't have that we
can't have Israel building in any of
these areas in Gush Katif
in in in Gush Etzion we can't have them
building anywhere in here because it
might make terrorist groups very very
angry and make peace harder okay that is
a dumb argument but it's not even close
to as dumb an argument is the argument
about senior Bernie Sanders make here's
Bernie Sanders is here's Bernie Sanders
being unbelievably radical threatening
Israel originals foreign aid over their
treatment of the Gaza Strip which is run
by Hamas it is run by an Iranian backed
terror group that fires rockets into
Israel routinely and my solution is to
say to Israel is you got 3.8 million
dollars every single year all right if
you want military aid you're gonna have
to fundamentally change your
relationship
people of Gaza in fact in fact I think
it is fair to say that some of that 3.8
billion dollars should go right now into
humanitarian aid in Gaza okay well what
is this is insane
okay the Gaza Strip what he is not
fundamentally changed your relationship
with what Hamas what are going to open
up the borders of the Hamas can suddenly
ship in military material which is what
they've been doing and then redirect all
of that humanitarian aids we're building
terror tunnels which is also what they
have been doing you know what's funny
about Gaza Strip get some beautiful
beaches right it's got some really nice
beachfront territory over there if that
were a place of law and order and
freedom how fast do you think
corporations would move in to build up
that area into a nice resort area the
answer is very very quickly how do we
know because the entire coastal line of
Israel is a nice resort area but in
order for that to happen
by the way Israel would love nothing
better than that like I've been speaking
to Israeli ministers you think Israel
wants to control the Gaza Strip you know
what they would love to have an
economically prosperous peaceful
neighbor that would be awesome or to
them like they would beg for that but
that's not what's going to happen if
Israel or to open up the borders with
with Hamas all that would happen is that
Hamas would ship in a bunch of military
material their literal stated goal is
the destruction of the State of Israel
in the murder of every Jew in the region
this is not a Giants this is not a in
any way a giant surprise but it but the
the you wonder why Republicans aren't
going to turn to the Democrats this is
why they're not going to turn to the
Democrats you want to know why they're
not gonna return to the Democrats
because Bernie Sanders is out there
saying that the reason to deal well with
police is that the police don't shoot
you in the back of the head there's
another thing the Bernie Sanders said
yesterday he said that the reason to
respect the police is so they don't
shoot you because that's what police do
routinely is they just if you're if
you're say something nasty to a police
officer all the time they just shoot you
directly in the back of the head all the
time I mean you look at that and then
you go
yeah I'm voting for Trump sorry sorry
you guys had all you had to do is not be
crazy and you just couldn't do it here's
Bernie Sanders being crazy if I'm your
son what a vice would you give me the
next time I might be full of about
police officer I would respect what they
are doing so that you don't get shot in
the back of the head I would be very
cautious if you were my son
terms of dealing with that police
officer but I also defend my rights and
know my rights and make sure if possible
that police officers camera is on what
goes on okay I mean just unbelievable
you have to respect the police they
don't shoot you in the back of the head
in a second I'm gonna show you why so
many Americans look at President Trump
they go yeah the guy's got foibles yeah
he's got character flaws yeah he may say
dumb bad things sometimes but I'm not
gonna vote for these guys I'll show you
that in just one second first let's talk
about what happened this morning I had a
very very rough evening so not only did
our rental car get screwed up through
circumstances I shall not deign to
mention but also we came home and then
my son decided you know buddy great idea
I'm just gonna projectile vomit
everywhere which is the joys of having
children guys I talk about it all the
time well that meant that we were up
very very late last night I was up early
this morning in order to record the show
and I needed coffee well what was the
kind of coffee that I like black rifle
coffee there's nothing quite like black
rifle coffee when it comes to giving you
a kick in the pants with tons of
different roasts to choose from black
rifle will ship the best roasts to order
coffee directly to your door a portion
of all black rifles profits go to
supporting veteran law enforcement fire
and first responder causes when you
drink black rifle coffee you're
supporting a company that serves coffee
and culture to people who truly do love
America I mean I know the guys have
found in black rifle coffee these are
awesome dudes many of them are military
veterans they are just the best like
people you'd want to hang out with and
people you want to do business with if
you've been on the fence about joining
the black rifle coffee Club there is no
better time than now help them reach
their goal of hitting 100,000 club
members by the end of this month get
access to discounted offers not
available to other customers visit black
rifle coffee calm /ban get 20% off your
first purchase that is black rifle
coffee calm slash burn for 20% off that
first purchase again black rifle coffee
calm slash been okay well we're gonna
get to more of why no sane person would
vote for the Democrats at this point but
first you have to go over to daily where
comment subscribe ninety-nine a month
ninety-nine bucks a year you know the
page plus we have the daily wire app
which is awesome and allows you to
communicate with me directly if you're a
subscriber you can access all of our
contents including articles shows and
more straight from the app all access
subscribers get our new exclusive
discussion features where they can
interact directly with our hosts writers
and other special guests the app is
available on Apple and Android so
download it today become a subscriber
and come join the fun go check us out we
have also
Goody's checks out a daily we're calm we
had largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so as you say you hear Bernie
Sanders say things like I'm gonna you
know you should cooperate with the
police so they don't shoot you in the
back of the head you heard him say stuff
like that you hear him say you know what
we really need to do we need to pressure
Israel into making concessions to Hamas
and and you say like no I'm sorry I'm
not voting for these people I'm not
voting for these people because they're
they're crazy I mean this is this is
nuttiness on the highest level and then
you hear Trump and you think to yourself
okay well at least he shares some basic
common sense values for example he was
talking to police yesterday and he says
to the police listen you don't hear it
enough you do a really good job the fact
that that is a political statement shows
you how far off the trail the Democrats
are why can't Democrats just say that
and say yes they're bad apples we're all
interested in rooting about including
good cops are interested in rooting out
bad apples nobody wants to see cops do
bad things but the police officers daily
are doing amazing work keeping you safe
and high crime areas don't need fewer
police officers they need more police
officers they need more of a police
presence here's President Trump saying
what used to be a common-sense thing
about the police you don't hear it
enough you do an incredible job the
people of this country know it and the
people of this country love you you
don't hear that from these people back
here but they love you every day of my
presidency I will be your greatest and
most loyal champion I have been and I
will continue to be I mean that is
common sense stuff and then Trump went
further he said listen I'm not gonna put
the needs of illegal immigrants over
law-abiding citizens most Democrats find
this offensive most Americans as a
general rule say this sounds like
perfect common sense why exactly
wouldn't we favor American citizens over
people who are here illegally people
like Johnson put criminals and illegal
aliens before the citizens of Chicago
and those are his values and frankly
those values to me are a disgrace I will
never put the needs
of illegal criminals before I put the
needs of law-abiding citizens it's very
simple to me okay I mean the fact that
from says disorder like this is why from
supporters go okay if I have a choice
listen with all of all the other crap if
I chose to be NAT and Bernie Sanders
saying that cops are gonna shoot in the
back of the head or Joe Biden saying
that white people don't get pulled over
by cops like not much of a choice is it
all they had to do is not be crazy and
they couldn't do it that's all Democrats
had to do was not be crazy and each and
every day there's arrangement of the
fact that Trump is the President of the
United States is even more on display so
for example the people were cheering the
other night because President Trump went
over to Washington DC he went to the
Nationals Park for the for Game five
between the Nationals and the Houston
Astros and he was roundly booed by the
crowd and a lot of people on the Left
were cheering this now a few people on
the left for like ah this isn't a good
look but the fact is of course he was
booed Washington DC voted 96% for
Hillary Clinton of course he was booed
okay but most Americans look at that and
they go he's still kind of the
presidents of the United Mall that much
but he's still kind of the President of
the United States and that's not a
fantastic look it is not a great look
and then you have incidents like this
one that was making the rounds on social
media
there's a rapper named yg that stands
for and I guess is given name I don't
know in any case he brings a white guy
onto stage at one of his concerts and
asked him to say eff Donald Trump and
the guy said no and here's what it
sounded like
come here I spotted riding the crown
I actually trap you say you don't know
so since you don't know I need you to
make up your mind tonight I need you to
scrub set your name I want you to state
your name cuz I know your mama your
daddy can grab my butt your
grandfather's watching I want you to
search I found the truck no you won't
get his ass out of here
okay is that a book I mean like really
is that a good look when was the last
time you had somebody come to a concert
by a country star and the country star
brought them upstate on stage and said I
need you to shout F Barack Obama and if
you don't get them that out of here
right that is that the kind of like most
Americans I think a lot of Americans
conservatives to suppose specifically
look at that and they say this is how
the left thinks of us but left their
radical they hate all of our priorities
they don't like us very much they sneer
at us they won't have us at that are
like I'm sure that guy was just there to
listen like he paid for entry presumably
into that concert or at least he paid to
get that even if it was a free concert
which I don't know like he was there to
be a fan and he was called onstage and
humiliated for the great sin of not
saying F the President of the United
States on stage by the way I wouldn't
say F Barack Obama one brought like if
somebody had called me up on stage and
said I want you to shout F Barack Obama
on stage in 2015 I wouldn't done it I
wouldn't have done it because the
sitting president of the United States
as much as I may despise who the sitting
president is is still the sitting
president of the United States it's a
very bad look most Americans see that
and they say okay if this is the left
how could I possibly side with them how
is that even a possibility the right in
America believes that the left are
coming for them and despise them the
middle in America look at the far left
which is taken control of the Democratic
Party and they're afraid to and this
should be afraid because the Democratic
Party is unfortunately staffed by people
who are so far to the left that it's
making even kind of normal Democrats
blush at this point you know take a
perfect example so Chicago
not exactly a right-wing bastion is
currently suffering from a teachers
strike there are 25,000 teachers on
strike and third and 300,000 children
out of the classroom they're striking
against the black I believe lesbian
mayor of Chicago a Democrat named Lori
Lightfoot okay so she's about as
intersectional as it gets and she is and
she's being struck against by the
Chicago Public School teachers and
Elizabeth Warren showed up on the picket
lines and other Democrats showed up on
the picket lines Chicago literally has
no money you think that Lori Lightfoot
doesn't want to sign a deal with its
with the teachers unions are you crazy
she's a Democrat of course she does but
the radical
taken such control of the Democratic
Party that even people who are mildly
responsible for running cities are like
we can't run the city how exactly is
this a like how how Chicago's teachers
represents it is according the
Washington Post represented by a
powerful union in an overwhelmingly
Democratic City last went on strike in
Thursday's strike idled some 25,000
teachers and 300,000 students the
Chicago Teachers Union and Mayor Lori
Lightfoot who faces her first major test
and city leader reached a contract
impasse forcing Lightfoot to cancel
classes on Thursday teachers were joined
on the picket lines by special education
assistants bus aides school security
guards and other staff represented by
the SEIU Local 73 whose contract
negotiations with the city also stalled
Lightfoot has said the city can't afford
the teachers demands which include a
restorative justice coordinator for
every school restorative justice
coordinator what in the world is that
job
you walk around restoring justice what
are you a superhero a restorative
justice coordinator she told the
reporters Thursday morning the schools
remain closed and teach until teachers
agreed to come back to the classroom you
think Lori Lightfoot doesn't want to
sign a deal some teachers on the picket
line said they're battling to Forrest
Lightfoot to hew to her campaign
platform which emphasized educational
justice teachers are hoping to force the
city to commit to easing a housing
crisis that has driven out many of the
city's black resident more than 16,000
students were counted as homeless in
2018 Lightfoot said at a Wednesday news
conference she was dismayed by the
union's job action said I was
disappointed by the decision to begin a
work stoppage and force the cancellation
of classes we reiterated that our
proposal was rooted in our admiration
for the job that educators and school
staffers do every day like Democrats
have so they've gone so far off the path
that even Democrats weren't even
responsible for just like what's Lori
Lightfoot supposed to do with that and
then you have the Democratic
presidential candidate setting in to
stand with the picketers against Lori
Lightfoot
it's insane it's insane and on top of
that you had the cultural battles on top
of that you add the canceled culture
that is promoted by the left there's a
crazy article in The Washington Post
today by some dude named Aaron Friedman
a writer based in Brooklyn New York
which well I mean if I were a writer
based in Brooklyn New York I'd certainly
get a column in the in the wash
in post he mean a writer who's also
based in Brooklyn New York and what a
credential because there's nobody who
writes in Brooklyn New York
aside from every person in Brooklyn New
York overlooking a smelly garbage dump
well they look out back there's a bum
drinking from a from a liquor bottle and
and then you just write about that and
then you become I guess the foreign top
foreign policy I'd to President Obama
actually is how Ben Rhodes got a job so
that's that that's good stuff
writer from New York writing for The
Washington Post critics of canceled
culture really just hate democracy so in
other words if you oppose the cancel
culture which attempts to not say I'm
not gonna go see the show or I'm not
gonna listen to the show or I'm not
gonna listen to this website or
something if you do all of those things
right it's not about that it's really
more about are you going to go after
people's advertisers and livelihood and
the answer for that on the left is a
resounding yes they want to do that
canceled culture is not about you know
what I don't like what Louis D cated I'm
not going to the show anymore and maybe
other people shouldn't go to a show it's
not about that it's about if you go to
Louie CK show I won't have dinner with
you if you go to Louie CK show this
makes you a bad person if you listen to
that Dave Chappelle special man no one
should listen to Dave Chappelle Netflix
should be ashamed for even
green-lighting that thing it's about the
lower downs at Netflix going to their
boss and being like how could you
possibly green like that Dave Chappelle
special probably you shouldn't do it
next time I cancel culture is about
canceling it's not about you not wanting
to participate in patronage of some
artists everybody does that all the time
that is merely called making a decision
like we do that every single day there's
certain things I like to watch certain
things you like to watch and they may
not match cancel culture is about the
mobilisation of fake armies on Twitter
who don't actually care about these
issues to bother people in order to ruin
their businesses simply because you
don't like what they have to say but
Aaron Friedman says no no this is called
democracy there's some pretty funny
aspects of this particular column he
says cancel culture is best understood
through its critics
from social media pundits such as ben
shapiro and claire layman to a growing
chorus of mainstream writers like Barry
Weiss and Brett Stevens there you will
find a familiar line of argument once
upon a time Americans tolerated and even
embraced uncomfortable views and
problematic people but now when someone
is ratioed on twitter or protested at a
panel discussion or booed during a
comedy set it supposedly offers evidence
that
are afraid of ideas that challenge them
and casting out those they disagree with
cancel cultures critics argue the public
is excluding the very ideas it needs
most strip away this intellectual gauze
and the critics of canceled culture have
a pretty simple argument as yasha monk
recently endorsed in the Atlantic if
everyone always agrees with you you're
doing it wrong in other words don't
trust your own opinions unless you
reflexively heed those who you dislike
no matter how good reason you have for
shunning them you're doomed to live as
an intellectual sheep this sentiment is
more than just petty contrarian ism
apply it in the real world says this guy
and it becomes clear that contempt for
canceled culture is little more than
contempt for democracy so just to get
this straight according to this
columnist for The Washington Post if I
take the position you shouldn't be so
sure of your own opinion and you should
listen to other people's opinion that's
called contempt for democracy contempt
for democracy if I say that you should
patronize whatever business you want but
it is an active badge to try and destroy
somebody's livelihood based on you
disagree with them that is contempt for
democracy democracy can only work if you
try to mobilize people to destroy your
neighbors business that's how democracy
is supposed to work according to this
columnist for The Washington Post and by
the way I would I would venture to guess
that many of the mainstream Democratic
presidential candidates agree with this
this comment says well our society
rightly values protest and free
expression the critics of canceled
culture turned this virtue into a vice
contemptuously dismissing those who
collectively expressed their disapproval
No if you want to collectively express
your disapproval I have it by the way
you can go to my lectures I have overtly
thanked protesters who come to my prota
come to my lectures and said they're
expressing their freedom of speech they
may be wrong and they think they're
stupid but they're expressing their
freedom of speech good for them that's
not the problem
the problem is when you fake an outrage
wave and then go after someone to ruin
their career protest as much as you want
say you don't want people listening to
my show as much as you want go after
advertisers who have nothing to do with
the show other than they want access to
audiences go after my audience and call
them a bunch of alright white
supremacists suggest I should be taken
off the air that's a different thing
that's canceled culture and that's what
so many people are kicking back against
that's where Trump's culture warrior
status really benefits him because all
the Democrats had to do again all they
had to do was not be crazy and they just
couldn't do it and the ones who are not
as crazy like Joe Biden who slightly
crazy and most of the other Democrats
are just weak you got the crazy and you
got the weak and that's who I'm said
those are the people we are supposed to
throw trump over for why why because
Trump doesn't understand his way around
the White House and like blunders a lot
and stumbles into things like a bull in
a china shop and says bad stuff on
occasion and like I'm sorry but no I'm
not turning over the levers of the most
powerful government in the history of
the world to people who actively want to
destroy every priority I believe in
because you have some qualms about
president from saying bad stuff on
Twitter like that's not a thing that's
not a thing okay we'll do a quick thing
I like and then we'll do a quick thing I
hate and then we'll be out of here so
quick thing that I like today so as I've
said before I'm not a dog person I will
say that on this trip we happen to be
renting a place that has a dog my kids
love it the dog loved it oh this is a
really nice dog and so they're turning
me they're hurting me but this dog as
nice as this dog is is not the very best
dog he's not the goodest dog the goodest
dog is this dog this dog is the greatest
dog of all time President Trump released
a photo of this dog quote we have a to
clap we have to classified a picture of
the wonderful dog and named Nazi
classified that did such a great job in
capturing and killing the leader of Isis
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi this is the very
best dog this is a good dog
yes very good I said yesterday that if
this dog had been decommissioned I would
have made a serious effort to adopt this
dog this is a very good dog killing
terrorists best dog ever
apparently this dog is also like super
dog according to the New York Post
military dog wounded chasing al-baghdadi
is already back on the job this is the
American dog of war who chased down and
cornered evil Isis leader Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi in his desperate final
moments before the terrorists blew
himself to hell with the suicide vest in
his dingy Syrian lair according to the
New York Post President Trump on Monday
afternoon tweeted a photo of the
four-legged hero clad in what appears to
be a camouflage harness and with his
tongue lolling out of its mouth be lying
it's u.s. army trained ferocity the
pooch apparently it's named Conan was
Unleashed after al-baghdadi when the
coward fled US troops down a dead-end
tunnel late on Saturday night apparently
Conan has already been cleared to return
to service
mark Milley the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff said the dog is still in
theater the dog performed a tremendous
service as they all do in a variety of
situations he was slightly wounded and
is fully recovering but the dog is still
in theater theater returned to duty with
its handler this dog is everybody's best
friend
yes good dog very good dog okay time for
a quick thing that I hate okay so I
don't actually hate this thing guys
don't let me just say this really
doesn't belong in things I hate but if
you're a Republican you should be a
little bit concerned so the House
Democrats are now calling repair now
calling Republicans Bluff what exactly
are they doing well apparently they're
going to vote on impeachment procedures
on Thursday to quote-unquote
ensure transparency so Republicans have
been claiming that Democrats are doing
everything behind closed doors because
they're very much afraid that if all of
the witnesses they are bringing are
exposed to the light then there's going
to be blowback because Republicans will
shred them in these hearings and it'll
be obvious that they didn't actually
have first-hand knowledge of the
negotiations or they were
misinterpreting Trump or that they had
other agendas
well now Democrats are I've never
understood why Democrats we're doing
this behind closed doors if they were so
confident of their case why not just do
it out in the open and the answer is now
they are according to the Washington
Post Democrat said the move would ensure
transparency and provide a clear path
forward they said that they are going to
put all of this on TV the White House
responded by taking a swipe at Democrats
press secretary Stephanie Gresham
accused them of conducting an
unauthorized impeachment proceeding and
declined to comment fully until the text
of the resolution is released apparently
they want to make this publicly
available and and this follows
immediately on on the revelation that
there was an army officer who heard
president Trump's Ukraine call and
reported his concerns up the chain this
is not the whistleblower apparently the
name is Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
Benjamin of the army and the top ukraine
expert on the national security council
apparently he twice registered internal
objections about how trump and his inner
circle were treating ukraine out of what
he called a sense of duty he plans to
tell the impeachment inquiry according
to a draft of his opening statement
obtained by the New York Times so all of
this is bad stuff for a president Trump
obviously and we will keep track of it
Plus we'd back here later today with two
additional hours of content I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Serling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavel why douse key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you